Welcome to another bonus episode of How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收看《我们如何创造了你的母亲》的另一集奖励。
We're hard at work on season two, which we'll launch very, very soon, and we're using this space now to share some appearances of the team on other great podcasts.
我们正在努力制作第二季，我们很快就会推出，我们现在利用这个空间来分享团队在其他精彩播客上的一些表现。
And today we bring you Craig Thomas' appearance on Hyperfocus.
今天我们为您带来克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 在《Hyperfocus》节目中的亮相。
Hyperfocus is a show that zeros in on what fascinates us about ADHD, mental health, and learning.
《Hyperfocus》是一档聚焦多动症、心理健康和学习方面让我们着迷的节目。
On this episode, Craig will talk about his son Elliot, who was born with Jacobson's syndrome, a genetic condition causing physical and developmental disabilities.
在本集中，克雷格将谈论他的儿子埃利奥特，他出生时患有雅各布森综合症，这是一种导致身体和发育障碍的遗传性疾病。
When Elliot was born, Craig's career was taking off with How I Met Your Mother, and he says, I was living an hour drama show at home and then driving to work and doing a sitcom.
艾略特出生时，克雷格的事业随着《老爸老妈的浪漫史》而起飞，他说，我在家看一个小时的戏剧，然后开车去上班，拍一部情景喜剧。
And his upcoming novel, That's Not How It Happened, is based in part on his family's experience.
他即将出版的小说《事情不是这样发生的》部分是基于他家人的经历。
Check out Craig now on Hyper Focus.
现在就来看看克雷格的《Hyper Focus》吧。
It's strange how we as a society don't have more and better answers for what adult lives look like for people with disabilities.
奇怪的是，作为一个社会，我们对于残疾人的成年生活是什么样子却没有更多更好的答案。
People with disabilities are human.
残疾人也是人。
They have parents and families who are humans and love them and deserve respect and decency and humanity dignity.
他们的父母和家庭都是人类，爱他们，值得尊重、体面和人性尊严。
That's Craig Thomas.
那是克雷格·托马斯。
You might not know his name, but you definitely know his work.
你可能不知道他的名字，但你一定知道他的作品。
He co-created How I Met Your Mother, and he's also been a writer on American Dad, the late show with David Letterman, made music for Sesame Street, and even written for The New Yorker.
他是《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的共同创作者，也是《美国爸爸》、大卫·莱特曼深夜秀的编剧，为《芝麻街》创作音乐，甚至为《纽约客》撰稿。
There are really colorful, wonderful ways to describe something that is absurd, stupid, ridiculous, hypocritical, hapless.
确实有很多丰富多彩、美妙的方式来描述荒谬、愚蠢、可笑、虚伪、不幸的事情。
There are so many funny ways to talk about those things without resorting to this incredibly easy punching-down, useless, outdated way of calling something those things.
有很多有趣的方式来谈论这些事情，而不必诉诸这种极其简单的、无用的、过时的方式来称呼这些东西。
If you've been listening to the last two episodes of Hyper Focus, you've already heard from Craig.
如果您已经听过《Hyper Focus》的最后两集，那么您已经听过克雷格的来信。
As we looked at how language, and especially the R word, echoes through comedy, culture, and everyday life.
当我们观察语言，尤其是 R 词如何在喜剧、文化和日常生活中产生共鸣时。
But this episode is about a lot more than that word.
但这一集的意义远不止这个词。
It's about Craig's journey as a father of a child with disabilities.
这是关于克雷格作为一名残疾儿童的父亲的旅程。
Because 18 years ago, while Craig was running a hit TV show, his son Elliot was born with a rare genetic condition called Jacobson Syndrome, which causes physical and developmental disabilities.
因为 18 年前，当克雷格正在主持一档热门电视节目时，他的儿子艾略特出生时患有一种罕见的遗传性疾病，称为雅各布森综合症，会导致身体和发育障碍。
And his life and perspective changed forever.
他的生活和观点永远改变了。
It'll be no surprise to anybody that Craig is very funny, but he's also a really thoughtful person when it comes to parenting, disability, language, and media.
克雷格非常有趣，这对任何人来说都不会感到惊讶，但在育儿、残疾、语言和媒体方面，他也是一个非常有思想的人。
And he has a unique perspective on what it feels like to look back at the culture that you helped shape and make the choice to do things differently.
他对回顾你帮助塑造的文化并做出以不同方式做事的选择的感觉有独特的视角。
And another reason we wanted to talk to Craig is because he recently tried his hand at something new, a novel.
我们想与克雷格交谈的另一个原因是他最近尝试了一些新的东西，一本小说。
It's called That's Not How It Happened.
这就是所谓的“事情不是这样发生的”。
And it's inspired by his family's story, a story that, like this episode, is as much about music and humor as it is about fear and love.
它的灵感来自他家人的故事，这个故事就像这一集一样，既关于音乐和幽默，也关于恐惧和爱。
He's not reducible to WebMD page of symptoms.
他无法将症状简化为 WebMD 页面。
He is not reducible to the R word.
他不能简化为 R 词。
He is not reducible to anything because he is a beautiful human being.
他不能被简化为任何东西，因为他是一个美丽的人。
I'm Ray Jacobson, and today on Hyper Focus, a longer conversation with Craig Thomas.
我是雷·雅各布森，今天在 Hyper Focus 节目中与克雷格·托马斯进行了较长的对话。
So how much your mother ended 10 years ago?
那么你妈妈10年前的结局是多少呢？
I lived in Los Angeles.
我住在洛杉矶。
I'm from New York, originally.
我原来是纽约人。
And we, my wife and I and my writing partner Carter, we all went to college together and we moved out to LA and we lived there for like 12 years, about 10 of which were doing homage to mother.
我们，我和我的妻子以及我的写作搭档卡特，我们一起上了大学，然后搬到了洛杉矶，我们在那里住了大约 12 年，其中大约 10 年是在向母亲致敬。
But we moved back here when the show ended and part of what happened during the run of the show, we had our son in between your two and three of how much mother and we had no idea what was gonna happen.
但是当节目结束时我们搬回了这里，并且在节目运行期间发生了部分事情，我们让我们的儿子在你们两三个人之间，有多少母亲和我们不知道会发生什么。
We had no idea in utero that he would be born with what turned out to be a very rare genetic syndrome.
我们在子宫内并不知道他出生时就会患有一种非常罕见的遗传综合症。
with all of these challenges, we'll get into it.
面对所有这些挑战，我们将全力以赴。
Health challenges, you needed open heart surgery at two weeks old.
健康挑战，您在两周大时需要进行心脏直视手术。
And then we only found out after the open heart surgery that it was all part of this larger syndrome called Jacobson syndrome.
然后我们在心脏直视手术后才发现，这都是雅各布森综合症这一更大综合症的一部分。
Not spelled exactly like your last name, right?
拼写与你的姓氏不完全一样，对吗？
The Swedish way, right?
瑞典方式，对吧？
It's a Swedish way.
这是瑞典人的方式。
Yes, it is discovered by a Swedish doctor, so well played.
是的，是瑞典医生发现的，打得很好。
Yes, that's you discovered it named after Jacobson and Sweden, that Dr. Jacobson, but we say Jacobson here.
是的，你发现它以雅各布森和瑞典命名，即雅各布森博士，但我们在这里说雅各布森。
And it's, you know, it's this really complicated, rare syndrome.
你知道，这是一种非常复杂、罕见的综合症。
It's a deletion of part of one of the 11th chromosomes.
这是第 11 号染色体之一的部分缺失。
And it has medical ramifications and developmental, intellectual ramifications, all kinds of things.
它具有医学影响、发展、智力影响以及各种各样的影响。
And we, you know, and yet I still had to be running this comedy TV show every week, you know, it was this really interesting balance.
我们，你知道，但我仍然必须每周运行这个喜剧电视节目，你知道，这是一种非常有趣的平衡。
But you know, he said, I was sort of living, I was living an hour drama show at home and then driving to work and doing a sitcom.
但你知道，他说，我有点生活，我在家里看一个小时的戏剧，然后开车去上班，拍一部情景喜剧。
It was just the weirdest thing.
这是最奇怪的事情。
I was like a full, a whole slate of content, traumatic and community content.
我就像是一整套内容、创伤性内容和社区内容。
And so, yeah, we moved.
所以，是的，我们搬家了。
My wife and I really wanted to move back where we had family support, where we were from.
我和我的妻子真的很想搬回我们有家人支持的地方，我们来自的地方。
So that's what we did at the end of How I Met Your Mother.
这就是我们在《老爸老妈的浪漫史》结尾时所做的。
And professionally, since then, I've, well, for one thing, we had another kid.
从职业角度来说，从那时起，我，嗯，一方面，我们有了另一个孩子。
And so I have my daughter Celia.
所以我有了我的女儿西莉亚。
She's nine.
她九岁了。
And she's neurotypical.
而且她很神经质。
She's a healthy, precocious little girl.
她是一个健康、早熟的小女孩。
She's very, she's different from her brother and yet they connect quite beautifully, the two of them.
她和她哥哥非常不同，但他们两个的联系却非常美妙。
Despite this nine-year age gap, my son just turned 18, which is a whole other conversation.
尽管年龄相差九岁，但我儿子刚刚满 18 岁，这完全是另一回事了。
I have so many questions.
我有很多问题。
Seven-year-old, yeah.
七岁了，是的。
And so my daughter's nine, my son is 18.
我女儿 9 岁，我儿子 18 岁。
And we move back here and part of my mission, after moving back, well, one of my missions was to not be such a workaholic and be more available to say, have a second child and be with my children because running a TV show is such a full-time job, so all-consuming.
我们搬回这里，也是我使命的一部分，搬回来之后，嗯，我的使命之一就是不要成为一个工作狂，更愿意说，生第二个孩子，和我的孩子们在一起，因为经营电视节目是一项全职工作，非常耗时。
And then, you know, like I said, we didn't know we were about to become the parents of a child with a disability, and suddenly you are.
然后，你知道，就像我说的，我们不知道我们即将成为一个残疾孩子的父母，而突然间你就知道了。
And there were six more years of how much a mother to do, or however many more years.
作为一个母亲，还有六年的时间，或者还有多少年的时间。
And it was like, it was a lot.
就好像，很多。
It was a lot to juggle.
有很多事情需要兼顾。
So since then, I have had part of my mission, besides finding more balance, has been finding ways to write about this, finding ways to write about this experience, of becoming the parent, my son, Elliot, and all of the challenges and fears that came with that and all of the massive, beautiful gifts that have come from being Elliot's dad.
所以从那时起，我的使命的一部分，除了找到更多的平衡之外，一直在寻找方法来写这个，想办法写这个经历，成为父母，我的儿子艾略特，以及随之而来的所有挑战和恐惧，以及作为艾略特父亲所带来的所有巨大而美丽的礼物。
And so I've been trying, I tried for a couple years, a few years in TV and film to do projects that incorporated aspects of that part of my life.
所以我一直在尝试，我尝试了几年，在电视和电影领域尝试了几年，去做一些融合了我生活的这一部分的项目。
And it's really hard to get Hollywood to green light TV shows or movies about those topics sometimes.
有时，要让好莱坞批准有关这些主题的电视节目或电影确实很难。
very close on a couple things.
在一些事情上非常接近。
There's still one that I'm still trying to push up the hill a little bit, but this is a very long answer to what am I doing now.
还有一个我仍在尝试将其推上山，但这是对我现在正在做的事情的一个很长的答案。
What am I doing now?
我现在在做什么？
The last two or three years, I've written my first novel, and it is very much about this.
在过去的两三年里，我写了我的第一部小说，它与此有关。
The book is called That's Not How It Happened, and it is, I hope, a funny, and yet going into luck at a family kind of like mine.
这本书的名字是《事情不是这样发生的》，我希望这本书很有趣，但在像我这样的家庭中却很幸运。
It's not exactly my family, but it's a family.
这不完全是我的家人，但它是一个家庭。
It's a mom, a dad, and two kids.
这是一个妈妈、一个爸爸和两个孩子。
There's a son who's about 24 with Down Syndrome, and he's sort of entering into adult life, right?
有一个大约 24 岁的儿子，患有唐氏综合症，他已经进入成人生活了，对吧？
He's in that process of what does adult life look like for somebody with a disability.
他正处于残疾人成年生活的过程中。
And he has a younger sister who in the novel is 17, coming up and graduating high school, and the mother and the father in their various ways are sort of standing on a cliff.
他还有一个妹妹，在小说中她已经 17 岁了，即将高中毕业，而母亲和父亲以各种方式都有点站在悬崖上。
Whenever I talk to somebody about, you know, another parent with a disability that has a child with a disability who is coming up on 18, 19, 20 years old.
每当我和某人谈论另一位残疾父母，他们有一个即将 18、19、20 岁的残疾孩子。
Without fail, they use the metaphor of a cliff.
他们无一例外地使用了悬崖的比喻。
That's what it feels like, right?
就是这样的感觉，对吧？
They go, well, we're coming up on that cliff.
他们走了，好吧，我们快到悬崖了。
And I would say my novel is sort of about that cliff and about sort of what coming up on that cliff does for all of them.
我想说我的小说是关于那个悬崖的，以及关于登上那个悬崖对他们所有人的影响的。
And the little cliffs they're all kind of standing on of like these inflection points that will lead in different directions for all four lives in this family.
他们所站立的小悬崖就像这些拐点，将引导这个家庭的四个人走向不同的方向。
So the book is told from four perspectives, all four of the narrators are those four characters.
所以这本书是从四个角度讲述的，四个叙述者都是这四个人物。
It's such a huge part of my life.
这是我生活中很重要的一部分。
Writers write what they know a great deal of the time.
作家大多时候写他们所知道的东西。
And I thought, I need to write something and put something out in the world about this topic.
我想，我需要写一些关于这个话题的东西并向世界发布一些东西。
And the best way to do it was for the final product to be words on a page rather than a script that a studio needs to green light and spend millions of dollars on, which just wasn't necessarily happening when I wrote those.
最好的方法是让最终产品成为页面上的文字，而不是工作室需要批准并花费数百万美元的脚本，而当我编写这些脚本时，这不一定会发生。
So that is a very long answer.
所以这是一个很长的答案。
Forgive me of what am I doing now?
请原谅我现在在做什么？
That was a 10 year ramp up to what am I doing now?
那是我现在所做的事情的十年进步？
That's amazing, and first of all, I love a thorough answer, and suddenly, you know, the idea of having an 18-year-old kid, period, let alone an 18-year-old kid who has disabilities who is going into the world in this new way, like the Cliff metaphor, I can feel it, this release.
这太棒了，首先，我喜欢一个彻底的答案，突然间，你知道，有一个 18 岁孩子的想法，就这样，更不用说一个 18 岁的残疾孩子，他将以这种新的方式进入世界，就像悬崖的隐喻一样，我能感觉到，这个版本。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
It's always the metaphor, and I wrote it into the book.
这总是比喻，我把它写进了书里。
I wrote it into the book that way, because everyone says it that way, because it feels that way, it's such an unknown and it's strange how we as a society don't have more and better answers for what adult lives look like for people with disabilities, right?
我就是这样写进书里的，因为每个人都这么说，因为感觉都是这样，这是一个未知数，奇怪的是我们作为一个社会对于残疾人的成人生活是什么样子没有更多更好的答案，对吧？
I mean, it's hard enough sort of navigating everything, educationally, everything, all of your child's health needs, health insurance, all those things that are part of child, that IEPs, all of that stuff.
我的意思是，在教育方面，所有事情，所有孩子的健康需求，健康保险，所有属于孩子一部分的事情，IEP，所有这些东西，都已经够难了。
But then there is some sort of a roadmap and then sort of right around 21 and getting into that you really, you start to feel like you are looking down on this cliff, and you go, I don't know what's down there.
但是然后有某种路线图，然后大约在 21 点左右，进入那个你真的，你开始感觉你正在俯视这个悬崖，然后你走，我不知道下面有什么。
We're going to take a leap of faith and see what happens.
我们将坚定信念，看看会发生什么。
And it is really strange to me how little of a roadmap, we seem to have to answer that question.
对我来说真的很奇怪，我们似乎必须回答这个问题，路线图是如此之少。
It's fascinating.
这很有趣。
You know, I keep hearing this from parents of kids with disabilities over and over and over, that there's sort of a map, or there is no map that it feels like everyone's trying to tracing a different path and that path is sort of terrifyingly individual and also feels very communal in this way that is like hard to explain to people who aren't part of the group.
你知道，我一遍又一遍地从残疾儿童的父母那里听到这样的话，有某种地图，或者没有地图，感觉每个人都在试图追踪一条不同的道路，这条道路有点可怕的个人化，而且以这种方式感觉非常公共，这很难向不属于该群体的人解释。
Yes, it's very hard to explain it.
是的，这很难解释。
Yeah, and the idea that you wrote a book that like takes people into the experience is so beautiful to me.
是的，你写一本让人们体验这种体验的书的想法对我来说真是太美好了。
But I wonder if I can take you kind of back because you are in this world now and it sounds like you inhabit it so fully and are able in a way that like I think is really rare because I keep hearing this from parents, to bring other people in.
但我想知道我是否可以带你回去，因为你现在就在这个世界上，听起来你完全融入了这个世界，并且能够以一种我认为非常罕见的方式，因为我不断从父母那里听到这样的说法，把其他人带进来。
But before you had Elliot, before you were in this group, before you were on this map, what was your relationship with disability-like?
但在你拥有艾略特之前，在你加入这个群体之前，在你出现在这张地图上之前，你与残疾的关系是什么？
Like, you started working in TV in your 20s, is that right?
比如，你20多岁就开始在电视行业工作，是吗？
Yeah, that's right.
是的，没错。
What did your relationship to the disability community look like then?
当时您与残疾人社区的关系是什么样的？
Yeah.
是的。
I viewed it with...
我用...查看了它
I didn't understand it.
我不明白。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
I viewed it.
我看过了。
I had so much much naivete.
我有太多的天真。
I had so much ignorance.
我真是太无知了。
I always felt sort of a kinship with people who had disabilities.
我总是对残疾人有一种亲切感。
I was friends with people who had disabilities in school, but I didn't have some larger understanding of what it really was.
我在学校里和一些残疾人是朋友，但我对残疾人的真正含义并没有更深入的了解。
One of my closest friends had cerebral palsy and he was just this awesome guy.
我最亲密的朋友之一患有脑瘫，他是一个很棒的人。
He was very athletic.
他非常有运动天赋。
He limped.
他一瘸一拐的。
He had different body challenges, but he was so good at baseball and tennis, he was amazing.
他面临着不同的身体挑战，但他非常擅长棒球和网球，他太棒了。
He was just my friend.
他只是我的朋友。
But I noticed as we got into junior high school in high school that people would make fun of him, sometimes.
但我注意到，当我们进入初中或高中时，人们有时会取笑他。
And I thought to myself, this guy's a better athlete than you are, you jerks.
我心想，这家伙的运动能力比你们好，你们这些混蛋。
What are you talking about, Stavoir?
你在说什么，斯塔瓦尔？
And overcoming some certain challenges.
并克服一些特定的挑战。
But it was funny, with that friend, who I was friends with all the way through high school, we never talked about his disability.
但有趣的是，和那个朋友，我在高中一直都是朋友，我们从来没有谈论过他的残疾。
It was the 1980s into the 1990s.
那是 20 世纪 80 年代到 90 年代。
We never really talked about it, or his identity, or what it meant, what it felt like he was just my friend, and I grew up at two, I have a cousin with who has Down Syndrome, and he, you know, we weren't close, we didn't live in the same town, but I always loved him, and he always had a great spirit, he's still with us, and he, I don't know, when you have somebody in your family with a disability, I think it does make you less inclined to be a bully or to make fun of people with disabilities, but it's not like it gives you, especially in the 80s and 90s, when I was growing up, it's not like there was some really robust, nuanced understanding of it or discussions about it.
我们从来没有真正谈论过它，或者他的身份，或者它意味着什么，感觉他只是我的朋友，我两岁时长大，我有一个患有唐氏综合症的表弟，他，你知道，我们并不亲密，我们不住在同一个城镇，但我一直爱他，他总是有一个伟大的精神，他仍然和我们在一起，而他，我不知道，当你家里有残疾人时，我认为这确实会让你不那么倾向于欺负残疾人或取笑残疾人，但这并没有给你带来什么，特别是在 80 年代和 90 年代，在我成长的过程中，并没有对它有一些真正强有力的、细致入微的理解或讨论。
No, not at all.
不，一点也不。
So I wouldn't say that I had a particularly deep understanding of it beyond the people I happened to know had disabilities.
所以我不会说我对它的理解比我碰巧认识的残疾人有特别深刻的理解。
And I'm curious about what that looked like when you started in media, because I think we're in a similar age group.
我很好奇当你开始从事媒体工作时会是什么样子，因为我认为我们处于相似的年龄段。
And what I remember is that- You're also a 35 grade.
我记得的是——你也是35级的。
Yeah, I'm going to be- I've been 35 for like, maybe five years.
是的，我会——我已经 35 岁了，也许五年了。
It's funny how you get there, and you just don't have an 18-year-old, I'm 35 anyway, it's just weird, yeah.
很有趣的是，你是如何到达那里的，而且你没有一个 18 岁的人，反正我已经 35 岁了，这很奇怪，是的。
I'm so glad that we're both 35, it's a great age to be.
我很高兴我们都35岁了，这是一个伟大的年龄。
We look amazing.
我们看起来棒极了。
We do.
我们做到了。
Of course, no work done.
当然，没有完成任何工作。
But in that way that when you become conscious of something, I have learning disabilities, but they're invisible, no one who would speak to me would necessarily know.
但这样一来，当你意识到某件事时，我就有了学习障碍，但它们是无形的，没有人会和我说话一定会知道。
I was always able to mask pretty effectively.
我总是能够非常有效地掩盖。
I'm a girl with ADHD, so I was not just masking but fully missed.
我是一个患有多动症的女孩，所以我不仅仅是掩饰，而是完全错过了。
missed.
错过了。
And in some ways that served me.
在某些方面这对我很有帮助。
But if I couldn't do something, I have to have dyscalculia.
但如果我不能做某事，我一定患有计算障碍。
I can't do math and other things.
我不会做数学和其他事情。
And if I was having a hard time doing something in my life, people have used the R word towards me.
如果我在生活中遇到困难，人们就会用“R”一词来形容我。
What do you do?
你做什么工作？
This, you know?
这个，你知道吗？
Right.
正确的。
Boy.
男生。
Makes my blood boil.
让我热血沸腾。
It's just makes my blood boil so much.
这让我热血沸腾。
Please keep going.
请继续。
I just need my blood to boil for a second.
我只需要我的血液沸腾一秒钟。
No, a lot of the blood boiling.
不，很多人热血沸腾。
That's what we we bring you here for is really a great you.
这就是我们带你来这里的原因，因为你真的很棒。
But you know, I feel like at the time, it didn't, it was like upsetting, but I also like, it was such a commonly used word.
但你知道，我当时觉得，它没有，这就像令人不安，但我也喜欢，这是一个如此常用的词。
And in my memory, it was pretty commonly used on television and in movies and in film and the way people with disabilities were depicted wasn't always, I mean, and I say was, was, was basically never thought over.
在我的记忆中，它在电视、电影和电影中非常普遍，而描绘残疾人的方式并不总是，我的意思是，我说是，是，基本上从未被考虑过。
Never.
绝不。
Yeah.
是的。
It was portable and never.
它是便携式的，而且从来没有。
Yes.
是的。
started working in TV and film, like do you remember hearing it?
开始从事电视和电影工作，你还记得听说过吗？
And I mean, I think I have like a picture of a writer's room in my mind and it's yeah, maybe not the kindest place.
我的意思是，我想我脑子里有一幅作家房间的照片，是的，也许不是最友善的地方。
There are those writers rooms for sure.
肯定有那些作家室。
There, yeah, still in reality, I'm going to be 50 in August, right?
是的，实际上，八月份我就满 50 岁了，对吧？
When my writing partner, Carter and I, we got hired at age 22 on David Letterman.
当我的写作伙伴卡特和我 22 岁时，我们被《大卫·莱特曼》录用了。
So we're these kids in the mid late 1990s.
我们都是 20 世纪 90 年代中后期的孩子。
And 100% people threw around that word at that point, without thinking twice about it.
100%的人在那时就抛弃了这个词，没有多想。
I even, I'll say this now because I've made such a crusade about this word.
我什至，我现在会这么说，因为我已经对这个词进行了如此大的改革。
I wrote this essay in the Boston Globe.
我在《波士顿环球报》上写了这篇文章。
I have published a short story and I were a review and now I've written a novel, all of which touch upon this.
我发表了一篇短篇小说，写了一篇评论，现在我写了一篇小说，所有这些都涉及到这一点。
The larger story and feeling and experience of being the parent of some of this ability, but specifically within that the words that are used and the diminishing dehumanizing ways that people with disabilities continue to be talked about even in 2025 and sadly there seems to be a real rise in the culture of talking about it that way and I know we'll get into that right in a second but like to just turn it back on myself for a second so I don't sound preachy and holier than now.
作为某些这种能力的父母的更大的故事、感受和经历，但具体来说，即使在 2025 年，人们仍然继续谈论残疾人所使用的词语和逐渐减少的非人性化方式，可悲的是，以这种方式谈论它的文化似乎真正兴起，我知道我们马上就会讨论这个问题，但我想把它转回到我自己身上，这样我听起来就不会比现在更说教和神圣了。
I didn't scold anyone for making are word jokes in 1997 or 2000.
在 1997 年或 2000 年，我没有责骂任何人开玩笑。
I don't think anyone did.
我想没有人这么做过。
To my great shame, I looked back not too long ago to screenplay.
令我非常羞愧的是，不久前我回顾了剧本。
Unproduced and didn't go anywhere that Carter and I wrote that had that word in it.
未制作，也没有出现在卡特和我写的任何有这个词的地方。
There was a joke where someone used that word.
有一个笑话，有人用了这个词。
This is something that 25-year-old Craig thought it would be okay to put in that screenplay, not understanding anything at the time.
25 岁的克雷格认为将这些内容放入剧本中是可以的，但当时他什么都不懂。
However old I was when I was working on that, almost 50-year-old Craig looked at this, recently like a couple months ago.
无论我从事这项工作时年龄多大，近 50 岁的克雷格最近（比如几个月前）都看过这个。
I was looking back through this old screenplay and I found that word and I sat with it.
我在回顾这个旧剧本时发现了这个词，然后我就坐下来。
It was like a punch in the face.
就像脸上挨了一拳。
It was proof that I had used that word in the past and that I had committed it to paper and thought it was okay because in the late 1990s it was a comedy word.
这证明我过去曾使用过这个词，并且我已将其写在纸上，并认为它没问题，因为在 20 世纪 90 年代末，它是一个喜剧词。
It was an edgy comedy word.
这是一个尖锐的喜剧词。
It's like a funny punchline to say, and I hate to say it, it seems like it's coming back.
这就像一个有趣的妙语，我讨厌说它，它似乎又回来了。
There are people in the culture now, and in politics now, dedicated to bringing this word back.
现在文化界和政治界都有人致力于将这个词带回来。
They're celebrating it.
他们正在庆祝。
Helping champagne.
帮忙开香槟。
We've reclaimed this word.
我们已经收回了这个词。
Like something has been achieved, like some great thing has happened by going back and finding this slur and saying, hey, no, we get to use a word that disparages the disability community to call anyone stupid and worthless.
就像已经取得了一些成就，就像发生了一些伟大的事情一样，回过头来发现这种诽谤并说，嘿，不，我们可以使用一个贬低残疾人群体的词来称任何人都是愚蠢和无价值的。
By association saying the disability community is stupid and worthless.
联想到残疾人群体是愚蠢且毫无价值的。
And the disconnect of seeing that, that those go hand in hand, they say, no, it's just a funny word.
看到这些是齐头并进的，他们说，不，这只是一个有趣的词。
It's actually not.
其实不是。
Words do actually matter.
言语确实很重要。
Yeah, they mean something.
是的，它们意味着一些东西。
They mean something and they shape how we think about certain types of people, right?
它们具有某种意义，并且塑造了我们对某些类型的人的看法，对吗？
The other thing is, if you talk to somebody in the disability community, I've heard wonderfully eloquent anti-R word speeches by people with Down syndrome, by people who say, I do not like how this word diminishes me.
另一件事是，如果你与残疾人群体中的某个人交谈，我听到唐氏综合症患者雄辩地发表了雄辩的反 R 词演讲，他们说，我不喜欢这个词如何贬低我。
And yet, the people who defend this word seem to say, no one cares.
然而，捍卫这个词的人似乎说，没有人在乎。
Everyone knows it's a word that's just cool and funny and comedic and no one thinks it's related to disability.
每个人都知道这个词很酷、很有趣、很喜剧，但没有人认为它与残疾有关。
That's just yet another lie because people with disabilities absolutely will tell you, no, that is a slur against my identity, like any other racial or religious epithets, slur, bigoted word.
这又是一个谎言，因为残疾人绝对会告诉你，不，这是对我身份的诽谤，就像任何其他种族或宗教绰号、诽谤、偏执词一样。
It is right.
这是对的。
The exact same as that.
和那个一模一样。
There is no difference between those things, and it's very hard to convince certain people of that fact for some reason.
这些事情之间没有区别，并且出于某种原因很难让某些人相信这一事实。
I'll never understand why.
我永远不会明白为什么。
But to bring him out of his own, there was a time where I thought as young man.
但要让他走出自己的困境，我曾一度作为年轻人思考过。
Apparently, I didn't even remember thinking this was true.
显然，我什至不记得我认为这是真的。
We're using this word particularly much, but there was staring me in the face in the screen plane.
我们特别频繁地使用这个词，但屏幕平面上有人盯着我的脸。
I really almost burst into tears when I saw it, because my son is now 18, and I've spent 18 years really reprogramming my mind and soul did, and just seeing the world so differently.
当我看到它时，我真的差点哭了，因为我的儿子现在 18 岁了，而我花了 18 年的时间真正重新编程了我的思想和灵魂，只是以不同的方式看待世界。
So my son was born in 2007, which is still quite a while ago, and I think a lot has been learned about how to talk about disabilities since then, and certainly since the late 1990s.
我的儿子出生于 2007 年，距今已经有很长一段时间了，我认为从那时起，尤其是从 20 世纪 90 年代末以来，我们已经学到了很多关于如何谈论残疾的知识。
But I remember going into my writer's room after my son was born and thinking, I've got to tell people you cannot make jokes like this around me anymore.
但我记得我儿子出生后，我走进作家的房间，心想，我必须告诉人们，你不能再在我身边开这样的玩笑了。
And I had to explain that.
我必须解释一下。
Now how I met your mother writer's room was full of all bighearted, wonderful people.
我是如何认识你母亲的，作家的房间里挤满了心地善良、优秀的人。
I don't know that word was ever tossed around in that way in that writer's room.
我不知道那个作家的房间里曾经以这种方式乱扔过这个词。
It was a really wonderful writer's room and they're not all like that.
这是一个非常棒的作家房间，但他们并不都是这样。
But just because I know how many writers do you play it fast and loose and throw around terms?
但仅仅因为我知道有多少作家，你就玩得又快又松，乱用条款？
And I just didn't even want to risk that anyone would think it was okay to say that word around me starting from my son's birth And I guess it's one of those you don't know till you know Yeah, you know, I think a lot when you say the how I met your mother's writers room was a kind and like loving place And large part it sounds like because you made it that way and I can only assume that's why that show resonated with so many people but I keep coming back to this idea of like we hear a lot about it and from the people who are celebrating using this word, we're being able to use it again as if they ever stopped in the first place.
我只是不想冒任何人会认为从我儿子出生开始就在我周围说这个词是可以的我想这是你不知道的一个直到你知道是的，你知道，当你说我如何认识你母亲的作家室是一个善良和充满爱的地方时我想了很多大部分听起来是因为你这样做了我只能假设这就是为什么那个节目引起了这么多人的共鸣但我不断回到这个想法我们听到了很多关于它的消息，并且从那些正在庆祝使用这个词的人那里，我们能够再次使用它，就好像他们从一开始就停止了一样。
It's just it's transgressive, it's funny, it's edgy, and I'm interested from your media perspective, this concept of, I don't know, it's like punching down, the shock value thing.
只是它是越界的，很有趣，很前卫，从你们媒体的角度来看，我很感兴趣，这个概念，我不知道，就像是打击，具有震撼价值的东西。
It is punching down.
它正在向下猛击。
Comedy was not designed.
喜剧不是设计出来的。
Comedy at its best does not punch down.
最好的喜剧不会让人失望。
It's not what it's about.
这不是它的意思。
That is not why it exists.
这不是它存在的原因。
As a motive expression, it's not bullying.
作为一种动机表达，这不是欺凌。
Comedy is not bullying.
喜剧不是欺凌。
Comedy is thought provoking.
喜剧发人深省。
Comedy is satirical.
喜剧是讽刺性的。
Comedy is looking at the world and commenting on it in a way that maybe no one else could save through a comedic lens.
喜剧正在以一种也许没有人可以通过喜剧镜头来拯救的方式来看待世界并评论它。
But boy, is it not bullying?
可是小子，这不是欺负人吗？
Boy, is it not being mean?
小伙子，这不是小气吗？
Being edgy comedy.
是一部前卫的喜剧。
And this was a thing like in the late 90s, early 2000s, and I think it's coming back.
这是 20 世纪 90 年代末、2000 年代初的事情，我认为它正在卷土重来。
Edgy Comedy is almost never funny, in my opinion.
在我看来，前卫喜剧几乎从来都不好笑。
It's almost never funny.
这几乎从来都不好笑。
We're doing this rewatch podcast for how I met your mother, Josh Radner, had this idea, he said, look, it's been 20 years since the show launched, which is insane, 20 years in the September of 2025, will be the 20 year anniversary from the launch, and it was- When I was 15 years old.
我们正在做这个重播播客，讲述我是如何认识你母亲的，乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 有这个想法，他说，看，这部剧开播已经 20 年了，这太疯狂了，20 年到 2025 年 9 月，将是开播 20 周年纪念日，那是——当我 15 岁的时候。
Well, flayed.
嗯，剥了皮。
That's what we call a callback.
这就是我们所说的回调。
See, that's clever comedy.
看，这真是一部聪明的喜剧。
That's not edgy punching down and bullying crappy comedy.
这不是前卫的打击和欺凌蹩脚的喜剧。
That was called clever.
这才叫聪明。
Yeah.
是的。
So we are rewatching and it's about 10 years since it went off the air.
所以我们正在重看，距离它停播已经过去了大约 10 年。
So is these two round numbers 10 and 20 and, Josh said, let's do this rewatch podcast.
这两个整数也是 10 和 20，乔什说，让我们重温一下这个播客。
Well, and so we're doing it.
嗯，所以我们正在这样做。
And I hadn't rewatched the show in years.
而且我已经很多年没有重温这部剧了。
And mostly the show is this very it is the most emo sitcom of all time.
这部剧主要就是这样，它是有史以来最情绪化的情景喜剧。
It is all like it wears its heart on its sleeve.
这一切就像是把心挂在袖子上一样。
It plays like a soap opera.
它像肥皂剧一样播放。
It plays like an hour drama.
它就像一个小时的戏剧一样。
It's serialized.
已经连载了。
It's a weird, it's a weird beast because it looks like a sitcom, but it's kind of not.
这很奇怪，这是一种奇怪的野兽，因为它看起来像情景喜剧，但事实并非如此。
I say these all as things I love about the show.
我说这些都是因为我喜欢这个节目。
I'm not saying it as a bet.
我这么说并不是为了打赌。
I think that's why the show works.
我想这就是这部剧成功的原因。
No, I think these are all marks.
不，我想这些都是标记。
I think those are all why I think that's what the show that's what was special and unique about the show.
我想这些就是为什么我认为这就是这部剧的特别之处和独特之处。
You've got to find what's your thing?
你必须找到你的事是什么？
What do you do better than other shows?
与其他节目相比，你在哪些方面做得更好？
And you say this is our thing.
你说这是我们的事。
and you commit to it, as a result, it is mostly not edgy comedy.
并且你致力于它，因此，它基本上不是前卫的喜剧。
But I will say this, we're only like 10, 12 episodes into the rewatch.
但我要说的是，我们只重看了 10、12 集。
I've already caught a few moments from 2005, where there's some joke where I go, I wouldn't do that joke today.
我已经捕捉到了 2005 年的一些片段，其中有一些笑话，我今天不会再讲这个笑话了。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
I wouldn't do exactly that joke.
我不会开那样的玩笑。
Maybe I wouldn't say that word.
也许我不会说这个词。
There's just a couple of times where, like the word transvestite is used to describe, like there was a transvestite hooker out on the street, like painting a picture of a crazy scene at three in the morning in New York.
只是有几次，就像异装癖这个词用来描述的那样，就像街上有一个异装癖妓女，就像在纽约画了一幅凌晨三点疯狂的场景。
It wasn't meant to be insulting into that community, but it's singling out that word.
这并不是要侮辱那个社区，而是单挑这个词。
It was using that word in a way to say like, how crazy is New York at three in the morning or whatever it is?
它使用这个词的方式是说，纽约凌晨三点有多疯狂或者其他什么？
And I don't, I look at it, it's like, that's sort of cheap and edgy.
我不，我看着它，就像，这有点廉价和前卫。
You're just saying that word because that word feels edgy.
你之所以说这个词只是因为这个词让人感觉很尖锐。
This is me, I mean, I don't know why this podcast is true.
这就是我，我的意思是，我不知道为什么这个播客是真的。
I'm just doing me a culpa's on this podcast now.
我现在只是在这个播客上道歉。
But I think it's important.
但我认为这很重要。
That's why we've been people.
这就是为什么我们一直是人。
I guess at the point I'm trying to make is you don't know, you do have to evolve.
我想我现在想要表达的是你不知道，你确实必须进化。
You do have to learn as you go.
你必须边走边学。
Even this open-hearted show that is full of love, how I'm a tramutter, we had a few moments as younger, right, comedy writers, 30 years old, when we launched the show, where we didn't realize some of those words, maybe you don't need to say those words as a part of a punch line of a joke, even if it wasn't your intention to insult somebody with that identity.
即使是这部充满爱的开放式节目，我是一个喜剧作家，我们也有过一些年轻、正确的喜剧作家的时刻，30岁，当我们推出节目时，我们没有意识到其中的一些话，也许你不需要把这些话作为笑话的妙语的一部分说出来，即使你无意侮辱具有这种身份的人。
It's still, you're name checking this word in this comedic way that isn't actually comedic.
仍然，你以这种喜剧的方式检查这个词的名字，但实际上并不是喜剧。
The point I'm trying to make here is that a couple of moments like that I've found so far rewatching the show, the jokes are not worth it.
我在这里想说的一点是，到目前为止，我在重看这部剧时发现有一些这样的时刻，这些笑话并不值得。
They're not funny.
他们并不好笑。
There was a better joke to say there, but it's just, that's my biggest thing.
那里有一个更好的笑话要说，但这就是我最重要的事情。
It's not actually funny, it's some stunt double of what people mistake to be funny and it's not.
这实际上并不好笑，它是一些人们误认为有趣的特技替身，但事实并非如此。
as like Joe Rogan and Elon Musk and these guys championing, re-ringing back from the nearly dead, the word, the R word.
就像乔·罗根（Joe Rogan）和埃隆·马斯克（Elon Musk）以及这些人一样，他们拥护、从濒临死亡的状态中重新唤起“R”这个词。
The R word, the measles.
R字，麻疹。
As if that is achieved anything and they are both very contagious.
好像这已经取得了任何成就，而且他们都非常有感染力。
Both of the two things you just named are contagious and people hear it and all their little followers hear it and they think this is an okay thing to say now.
你刚才提到的这两件事都具有传染性，人们听到了，他们所有的小追随者也听到了，他们认为现在说这是一件可以接受的事情。
And that anyone that tells you different that says don't use the R word is woke And when I very mistakenly, sometimes engage with people online about this topic, you better believe that their second or third move they have is to call you the R word right back.
任何告诉你不同的人，说不要使用 R 词都被吵醒了，当我非常错误地，有时与网上的人讨论这个话题时，你最好相信他们的第二个或第三个动作就是立即回叫你 R 词。
You're the R word for saying I can't use the R word and you're like, buddy, I don't know how to continue this lesson from here.
你是说我不能使用 R 词的 R 词，而你就像，伙计，我不知道如何从这里继续这一课。
I guess we're in an impasse, my friend.
我想我们陷入了僵局，我的朋友。
Yeah, I guess you win in your mind, but is that not really?
是的，我猜你心里赢了，但事实不是这样吗？
Well, this is like a thing I think about a lot, and it's kind of the thing that made me want to have these conversations in the first place, which is like, how do we take people who think this is funny or feel like it's just like, you know, people say they can't do it, they want to do it even more.
嗯，这就像我经常思考的一件事，这也是让我首先想要进行这些对话的原因，就像，我们如何对待那些认为这很有趣或感觉就像，你知道，人们说他们做不到，他们更想做的人。
And they just sort of sort of divorced from like what it actually means, what the impact really is.
他们只是有点脱离了它的实际含义和真正的影响。
Yeah.
是的。
This thing, it's a question that keeps coming back to me, which is like, you'll hear people be like, well, it's free speech, you know, like, I just want to use free speech.
这件事，这是一个不断回到我身边的问题，就像，你会听到人们说，嗯，这是言论自由，你知道，就像，我只是想使用言论自由。
and say what I feel.
并说出我的感受。
And it's like, to me, of course, you have free speech, but that is lazy speech.
对我来说，当然，你有言论自由，但那是懒惰的言论。
Yes.
是的。
You could find another word, like you're saying, you could come up, you could evolve, even if you said it before, you don't have to cleave to the thing you've always been, you can change.
你可以找到另一个词，就像你说的，你可以出现，你可以进化，即使你以前说过，你不必坚持你一直以来的样子，你可以改变。
There are really colorful, wonderful ways to describe something that is absurd, stupid, ridiculous, hypocritical, hapless.
确实有很多丰富多彩、美妙的方式来描述荒谬、愚蠢、可笑、虚伪、不幸的事情。
There are so many funny ways to talk about those things.
有很多有趣的方式来谈论这些事情。
Without resorting to this incredibly easy punching down, useless, like outdated way of calling something those things.
如果不采用这种极其简单的打击方式，毫无用处，就像过时的称呼方式一样。
Like think, be more, I would say challenge yourself to be more specific.
就像思考、变得更多一样，我想说的是挑战自己，让自己变得更具体。
What do you mean?
你是什​​么意思？
What do you think that word even means?
你认为这个词到底意味着什么？
Like, and also like, I think the, how do you get someone to stop saying this word?
就像，也像，我想，你如何让别人停止说这个词？
I don't know because I engage with people sometimes in social media and it once or twice, maybe a handful of times people have said, you made me think twice about this.
我不知道，因为我有时会在社交媒体上与人们互动，有一两次，也许有几次，人们说，你让我三思而后行。
I hear what you're saying.
我听到你在说什么。
Well, okay, I'll share why those exchanges worked, I think.
好吧，我想我会分享为什么这些交流有效。
Because I said, this is very hurtful to me, because sometimes it would be with like fans of how I met your mother even, or people that were engaging with me on some other issue.
因为我说过，这对我来说非常伤害，因为有时甚至会是我如何认识你母亲的粉丝，或者是那些在其他问题上与我接触的人。
And I'd say, look, if you like any of the work I've done, I just want you to know, I am a human being.
我想说，听着，如果你喜欢我所做的任何工作，我只是想让你知道，我是一个人。
I love my son more than anything in the world.
我爱我的儿子胜过世界上的一切。
And this word is a slur against an aspect of his humanity and his identity and a journey he's on.
这个词是对他人性、他的身份以及他所经历的旅程的诽谤。
think about it, he didn't ask for extra learning challenges in life, he didn't want that, but he has that and he has to overcome that and he deserves respect for that.
想想看，他没有要求生活中额外的学习挑战，他不想这样，但他有这个，他必须克服它，他值得尊重。
And to use words, these lazy prepackaged words that equate having a disability with the abstract concept of just stupidity, worthlessness, notlessness, if you're saying those two things are the same, they're not.
用词语来说，这些懒惰的预先包装的词语将残疾等同于愚蠢、无价值、无价值的抽象概念，如果你说这两件事是相同的，那么它们不是。
You're really hurting my feelings because my son is so important to me.
你真的伤害了我的感情，因为我的儿子对我来说非常重要。
So the times I've made it personal are the times when I've had to work.
所以当我必须工作的时候，我就把它当作个人的事情了。
But then if you make it personal and the person still says, F you, you're the R word, it hurts even more because now you feel like you've opened your heart to that person and like it didn't work and they just sort of like stabbed the dagger in a little deeper.
但如果你把它变得个人化，而那个人仍然说，F你，你就是R词，那就更痛苦了，因为现在你觉得你已经向那个人敞开了心扉，但好像这不起作用，他们就像把匕首刺得更深一点。
But the times it's worked are the times I've made it personal.
但它起作用的时候就是我把它变成个人的时候。
I see this word coming up a lot online, on social media, and it's thrown around in political discussions a lot.
我看到这个词在网上、社交媒体上频繁出现，并且在政治讨论中也经常出现。
I see it a lot in that sort of way where people say, libitard, you know what I mean?
我经常看到人们这样说，“libitard，你知道我的意思吗？”
Equating.
等同。
They're sort of just like, let me take what I perceive to be your political beliefs and equate it with that.
他们有点像，让我把我认为是你的政治信仰的东西与它等同起来。
I see all these different ways people are trying to bring it back.
我看到人们以各种不同的方式试图将它带回来。
And I think to myself, if they had somebody in their life that they loved, who had a disability and said to them, it really hurts my feelings.
我对自己说，如果他们生命中有一个他们所爱的人，一个有残疾的人，并对他们说，这真的会伤害我的感情。
When you use this, it really diminishes me and disparages me.
当你使用这个时，它确实贬低了我并贬低了我。
That might be the only way to get through to somebody like that.
这可能是与这样的人打交道的唯一方法。
I think there's a lot, I notice this phenomenon a lot where people only understand something abstract when it comes into their life in reality and specifically.
我认为有很多，我经常注意到这种现象，人们只有在现实和具体的生活中才能理解抽象的东西。
And so the challenge seems to be if somebody doesn't have that in their life, you have to talk about it in a way that makes it visceral, emotional, and real to them.
因此，挑战似乎是，如果某人的生活中没有这样的经历，你必须以一种让他们发自内心、情感丰富且真实的方式来谈论它。
And that takes a lot of trust because you're opening something up in your heart.
这需要很大的信任，因为你正在打开内心的某些东西。
If I talk about my son to somebody and they still insult me with the R word and say, you're just woke and screw off, that hurts more because I shared something of myself with that person.
如果我向某人谈论我的儿子，而他们仍然用“R”一词侮辱我，并说，你刚刚醒来并搞砸了，那会更伤害我，因为我与那个人分享了我自己的一些事情。
you know, I think you have to have an open heart and you have to try to talk to people about how it feels and that we are all human beings.
你知道，我认为你必须有一颗开放的心，你必须尝试与人们谈论它的感受以及我们都是人类。
We all have value.
我们都有价值。
This is a word that devalues.
这是贬义词。
This is a way of talking about disability.
这是谈论残疾的一种方式。
The devalues people.
贬低人的价值。
People disabilities are human.
人有残疾就是人。
They have parents and families who are humans and love them and deserve respect and decency and humanity and dignity.
他们的父母和家庭都是人类，爱他们，值得尊重、体面、人性和尊严。
And it's I just think my the only times that have felt a level of success and engaging with people is when I make it personal to them in some way.
我认为我唯一能感受到一定程度的成功并与人们互动的时候就是当我以某种方式向他们提供个性化的服务时。
And of course, I've now written a whole novel that I hope does that, and I hope it doesn't in a funny way.
当然，我现在已经写了一本完整的小说，我希望它能做到这一点，而且我希望它不会以一种有趣的方式。
It's mostly a comedic novel, and I find that comedy, the right kind of comedy, can disarm people and open them up, and I hope that I found a way of writing about it in my book that might open a few minds and might make people realize, oh, I see why this matters.
这主要是一部喜剧小说，我发现喜剧，正确的喜剧，可以解除人们的武装，让他们敞开心扉，我希望我在书中找到了一种写它的方式，可以打开一些人的思想，让人们意识到，哦，我明白为什么这很重要。
I see what this is.
我明白这是什么了。
This makes so much sort of sense to me as a constellation of things where it's like, if the comedy that punches down and is shock value and that's isolating, right, you're pushing people out, the kind of things that you create pull people in and it also like when you say, because I can really very much the feeling of having to make the thing that hurts personal in order to have other people care.
这对我来说是很有意义的，因为这一系列的事情就像是，如果一部喜剧具有冲击力，具有震撼价值，那是孤立的，对吧，你把人们赶出去，你创造的那种东西把人们吸引进来，就像你说的那样，因为我真的非常能体会到必须做出伤害个人的事情才能让其他人关心的感觉。
Like one of the questions that comes to me over and over and over as I do this work is, how do you get people to care about things that don't affect them?
就像我在从事这项工作时一遍又一遍地出现的问题一样，如何让人们关心那些不影响他们的事情？
And one of the only ways that I've seen that happen is through media, is through art, TV, books.
我见过这种情况发生的唯一方式之一就是通过媒体，通过艺术、电视和书籍。
You become intimately acquainted with characters that are not, you know, real people, but they feel very real to you.
你会逐渐熟悉那些不是真实人物的角色，但他们对你来说却非常真实。
And when you talk about writing the book, it's almost like, because I do feel like as people in the disability community, We do what you're saying.
当你谈论写这本书时，几乎就像，因为我确实觉得作为残疾人社区的人们，我们按照你所说的去做。
We have to kind of lay ourselves bare over and over and over and say, like, please care.
我们必须一次又一次地暴露自己，并说，比如，请关心。
Please care about this.
请关心这一点。
Please, please.
拜托，拜托。
And it's exhausting.
这很累。
Right?
正确的？
It's emotionally amazing.
这在情感上是令人惊奇的。
To plead it, you can do it sometimes, but there's almost no other way.
为了辩解，有时你可以这样做，但几乎没有其他办法。
Right.
正确的。
So it's like you have to like kind of like throw up in your chest and be like, look, I'm a person.
所以这就像你必须喜欢吐在你的胸口，然后说，看，我是一个人。
Just give some amount of a, give a care, as the seveners say, give a care.
只要给予一定量的a，给予照顾，正如七人所说，给予照顾。
And you know, but like that wears you out, it's tiring.
你知道，但这会让你精疲力尽，很累。
And you have to do it on a lot of fronts in a lot of ways.
你必须在很多方面以多种方式做到这一点。
And for me, when I see something like your book, or like that piece, which was so beautiful in the globe, you know, there's this beautiful level of removal, you know, you're making people care, you're making it personal personal, excuse me, you're making it personal through art.
对我来说，当我看到像你的书这样的东西，或者像那件在世界上如此美丽的作品时，你知道，有一种美丽的去除程度，你知道，你让人们关心，你让它变得个人化，对不起，你通过艺术让它变得个人化。
So it's almost like you have a screen in front of you, you're still, but you're still bringing people in.
所以这就好像你面前有一个屏幕，你是静止的，但你仍然在把人们带进来。
Yeah.
是的。
Which, I don't know, what do you think about that?
对此，不知道您有何看法？
Like what responsibility to media, to art have in this world because it feels to me like that's the biggest stage you can do this possibility.
就像媒体和艺术在这个世界上所承担的责任一样，因为在我看来，这是你可以实现这种可能性的最大舞台。
That's why I feel like we have to be out there.
这就是为什么我觉得我们必须走出去。
That's why I'm so glad you're you're doing this podcast.
这就是为什么我很高兴你做这个播客。
That's why I'm trying to write stuff about it.
这就是为什么我想写一些关于它的东西。
I think it's a huge responsibility.
我认为这是一个巨大的责任。
I think when people can be engaged on a human level, the way that an honest conversation in this podcast space could do, the way that I hope my book can do, the way I hope that piece out for the Boston Globe did, it has to be on a human level.
我认为，当人们能够在人性的层面上参与时，就像在这个播客空间中进行诚实的对话所能够做到的那样，就像我希望我的书能够做到的那样，就像我希望《波士顿环球报》的那篇文章所做的那样，它必须是在人性的层面上。
I think I think when it's abstract, people can swat it away and it remains abstract.
我认为当它是抽象的时，人们可以把它赶走，但它仍然是抽象的。
So much of human life now in 2025 is abstract.
2025 年，人类生活的大部分内容都是抽象的。
It's digital.
它是数字的。
It feels at a remove, right?
感觉很遥远，对吧？
It doesn't feel real.
感觉不真实。
And so it's how do you make it human?
那么如何让它变得人性化呢？
How do you make it visceral?
如何让它发自内心？
How do you give it a beating heart?
你如何赋予它一颗跳动的心？
And I think that's the huge challenge.
我认为这是巨大的挑战。
That Boston Globe piece I wrote was kind of admitted to my own ignorance a bit in ways that I've done in this interview too, where it sort of takes you through this journey of like I became the parent of a kid with disabilities.
我在《波士顿环球报》上写的那篇文章在某种程度上承认了我自己的无知，就像我在这次采访中所做的那样，它带你经历了这段旅程，就像我成为一个残疾孩子的父母一样。
And I was in Hollywood, and I was trying to figure out how to make the disability-parenthood part of my life fit, the Hollywood part of my life.
我当时在好莱坞，我试图弄清楚如何让残疾父母身份成为我生活中的一部分，融入我生活中的好莱坞部分。
And I wrote about the ways that it didn't fit, right?
我写了它不适合的方式，对吗？
I wrote about ways that I felt very lonely and unseen in Hollywood, and I didn't know how to talk about it myself.
我写了一些我在好莱坞感到非常孤独和被忽视的方式，我自己不知道如何谈论它。
And then retrospectively, I think about, If I could go back in time, I would have put people, I would have cast roles on how much mother, more often with people with disabilities, I would have made that visible on my show.
然后回想起来，我想，如果我能回到过去，我会让人们、我会扮演多少母亲的角色，更常见的是残疾人，我会在我的节目中让这一点可见。
I was so young, I was in my 30s, I didn't know how to be the parent of a kid with a disability, right?
我当时太年轻，才30多岁，我不知道如何成为一个残疾孩子的父母，对吗？
I had no knowledge, and I was trying to run that TV show and raise my son, and I wasn't coming at it with this higher level of awareness, and like realizing I should try to incorporate this into my work and make this visible an emotional palpable reel in my work, I thought they were two separate things.
我一无所知，我试图运行那个电视节目并抚养我的儿子，但我并没有以更高水平的意识来实现它，并且意识到我应该尝试将其融入到我的工作中并使其成为我工作中情感上明显的卷轴，我认为它们是两个独立的东西。
And now I realize that's not true, and I'm trying to make art and writing about this now, about this topic.
现在我意识到这不是真的，我现在正在尝试创作艺术并撰写有关此主题的文章。
But when I was doing how much mother, I didn't know how.
但当我做多少妈妈的时候，我不知道该怎么做。
And so that Boston Globe essay, I sort of call myself out a little bit and say, I wish I could go back in time and hire writers with disabilities and cast roles.
因此，在《波士顿环球报》的那篇文章中，我有点自言自语地说，我希望我能回到过去，聘请残疾作家和演员。
But I didn't, I just, I was not doing 3D thinking.
但我没有，我只是，我没有进行 3D 思考。
I was so day to day, just trying to like be there from my son and run this TV show.
我日复一日地只是想和我儿子在一起并主持这个电视节目。
And it was, I'll admit, it was like all too hard for me to think on that higher level.
我承认，对我来说，在更高的层面上思考是太困难了。
But now I'm trying more to think on that higher level and say, how can you put things out there in the world that humanize this?
但现在我正在尝试更多地在更高的层面上思考，并说，你如何才能把东西放在世界上，使这一点变得人性化？
How can you use whatever your little talents or skill sets are, whatever your ability to communicate is, like how do we do that?
无论你的小天赋或技能是什么，无论你的沟通能力如何，你如何利用，比如我们如何做到这一点？
How do we make it human?
我们如何让它变得人性化？
How do we make it a felt experience for people?
我们如何让它成为人们有感觉的体验？
Because if it stays abstract, people can insult and diminish and swat away things in the abstract that when they are face to face with it and it feels real, even if it's a novel, even if it's fictional, but if it feels real and you feel like real people, you can't dismiss it and disparage it so easily.
因为如果它保持抽象，人们就会侮辱、贬低和抛弃抽象的东西，而当他们面对面的时候，它感觉很真实，即使它是一部小说，即使它是虚构的，但如果它感觉真实，你感觉像真实的人，你就不能轻易地忽视它和贬低它。
You have to see the whole person.
你必须看到整个人。
And I want to ask you Ray, what did it feel like to you getting that word to throw in it?
我想问你，雷，你把这个词放进去有什么感觉？
What did that feel like, did that feel like, did you know, I don't know when you got your diagnosis or when you, to what extent you felt you were hiding and then people would say something to you, but it must have been like really shocking and horrible to have someone say something like that to you.
那是什么感觉，那感觉像吗，你知道吗，我不知道你什么时候得到诊断，也不知道你什么时候，你觉得自己隐藏到什么程度，然后人们会对你说些什么，但有人对你说这样的话一定是非常令人震惊和可怕的。
It felt like getting caught.
感觉就像被抓住了。
And you would just, but you also kind of do the thing, you know, like, and I think everybody at a young age does this when somebody says something that hurts you, right?
你会只是，但你也会做这样的事情，你知道，就像，我想每个年轻的人都会在有人说一些伤害你的话时这样做，对吗？
You just kind of like, oh, this kind of like shambling, brush it off, wiggle away from it.
你只是有点像，哦，就像步履蹒跚，把它刷掉，摆脱它。
But for me, because I knew that I wasn't, I've used this phrase a lot on this, and I keep saying that because I keep using it.
但对我来说，因为我知道我不是，所以我在这方面经常使用这个短语，并且我一直这么说，因为我一直在使用它。
But I knew that I was not like the others.
但我知道我和其他人不一样。
I was one of these things that was not like the others.
我就是这些与其他人不同的人之一。
I have ADHD, I have this calculator.
我患有多动症，我有这个计算器。
As a kid, I also had this graphia.
当我还是个孩子的时候，我也有这个 graphia。
I couldn't write, my spatial awareness is not great.
我不会写字，我的空间意识不太好。
But I could always cover.
但我总能掩护。
And so when somebody would say like, what are you, I would think like, oh my God, I didn't do it well enough.
因此，当有人说“你是谁”时，我会想，天哪，我做得不够好。
I would freeze and feel like I had been seen in a way that was not the way I wanted to be.
我会僵住，感觉别人以一种不是我想要的方式看待我。
noticed.
注意到了。
Did you literally have those diagnoses or those categories or labels upon it?
您确实有这些诊断或类别或标签吗？
I don't know, right?
我不知道，对吧？
You knew that you had challenges, maybe your parents knew, but you felt like you're just going to have to fit in because I'm assuming for contemporary ages that there was not much support or much recognition or much conversation on the levels that you would have needed it or that you would hopefully get today if you were a teenager today, but I, you know, assuming you felt very lonely and like, I felt very lonely.
你知道你面临着挑战，也许你的父母也知道，但你觉得你必须适应，因为我假设在当代，没有太多的支持或认可或太多的对话，而这些支持或认可或对话的水平是你所需要的，或者如果你今天是青少年的话，你希望今天得到的，但我，你知道，假设你感到非常孤独，我感到非常孤独。
Yes.
是的。
And also, I mean, I was lucky enough.
而且，我的意思是，我很幸运。
I have enough privilege to have been diagnosed at 21, which for a woman is frankly pretty early.
我有足够的荣幸在 21 岁时被诊断出来，坦率地说，这对于女性来说相当早。
And, but I failed out of school.
而且，但是我没能辍学。
I mean, I like crashed and burned in every conceivable way.
我的意思是，我喜欢以各种可以想象的方式崩溃和烧毁。
And, you know, if you were to look at like, what are the negative consequences of having learning disabilities on paper and being on diagnosed, like you could basically read my story up to about age 21.
而且，你知道，如果你看看纸上有学习障碍并被诊断出来会带来什么负面后果，就像你基本上可以在 21 岁之前读到我的故事一样。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
But that word for me and one of the things that I struggle with even in this conversation is when I'm like, I'm part of the disability community, because I was able to pass, because it wasn't something that I had to wear all the time, I feel sometimes like I'm like an imposter within that space.
但这个词对我来说，甚至在这次谈话中我也遇到的困难之一是，当我想，我是残疾人社区的一部分，因为我能够通过，因为这不是我必须一直穿着的东西，我有时觉得我就像那个空间里的冒名顶替者。
Like, you know, I could hide it.
就像，你知道，我可以隐藏它。
So do I really get to call myself disabled in this, like, to me, that feels like an inclusive word.
那么，我真的可以称自己为残疾人吗，对我来说，这感觉像是一个包容性的词。
I'm part of this wonderful community that is like a privilege to be part of.
我是这个美好社区的一部分，我很荣幸能成为其中的一员。
But I worry sometimes that when I use it, I'm like, my friend used to call for other things, fake the funk.
但有时我担心，当我使用它时，我会想，我的朋友过去常常要求其他东西，假装害怕。
Like, I'm, you know, like, so it was, it's a tricky word in that way of if you have an invisible disability, you both relate to it and experience it, but in a way that I think also when we hear from people with Down syndrome, where we hear from people who have clear disabilities that are like physically obvious, most of them say they've never had that word said to them.
就像，我，你知道，就像，原来如此，这是一个棘手的词，如果你有一种看不见的残疾，你就会与它联系起来并经历它，但在某种程度上，我认为当我们听到唐氏综合症患者的声音时，我们听到那些有明显身体残疾的人说，他们中的大多数人说他们从未对他们说过这个词。
Yeah.
是的。
Because what you're talking about, people don't, most people don't think of themselves as the kind of person who would show up and call someone who had a visible disability, the R word, but they're perfectly happy to use it online or you would put somebody who they don't realize is in the club.
因为你所说的，人们不这么认为，大多数人不认为自己是那种会出现并给有明显残疾的人打电话的人，“R”字，但他们非常乐意在网上使用它，否则你会把他们没有意识到的人放入俱乐部。
Yes.
是的。
Oh man, that is also fascinating.
噢，伙计，这也很有趣。
you saying you felt caught in that moment is just like so heartbreaking.
你说你在那一刻感觉被困住了，真是令人心碎。
And in terms of like you're at your identity, I mean to me, I'm the parent of a child with a disability and I write about this sometimes.
就你的身份而言，我的意思是，我是一个残疾孩子的父母，我有时会写到这一点。
I sometimes feel that way too.
我有时也有这样的感觉。
Do I have a right to write about this topic?
我有权利写这个话题吗？
I'm only the parent of somebody with a disability.
我只是一个残疾人的父母。
It's somebody who I love more than anything in the world.
这是我爱的人胜过世界上任何东西。
But I think we all have that imposter syndrome of what authority or authenticity to have talked about these things, but to me, for what it's worth, you're doing a beautiful thing by talking about all of this and your journey and you are part of that community and you're using your talents and your voice to talk about it and that makes you a part of the community and you already were too.
但我认为我们都有冒名顶替综合症，认为谈论这些事情有什么权威或真实性，但对我来说，无论它的价值如何，通过谈论所有这些和你的旅程，你正在做一件美丽的事情，你是这个社区的一部分，你正在利用你的才能和你的声音来谈论它，这使你成为社区的一部分，而且你已经是了。
So it's like, you should not overthink that, right?
所以，你不应该想太多，对吧？
We all need each other in this conversation.
在这次对话中我们都需要彼此。
And we are up against a culture that views, people with disabilities, and really ignorant distance of ways sometimes, and in ways that are invisible to them.
我们面临着一种文化，这种文化有时会以残疾人看不见的方式看待残疾人和真正无知的距离。
I think the argument for the R word is sometimes like, it's just a funny word.
我认为 R 词的争论有时就像，它只是一个有趣的词。
I'm not thinking of a person with a disability when I say that.
当我这么说时，我并不是在想一个残疾人。
The problem is, it does hurt the feelings of people with disabilities.
问题是，它确实伤害了残疾人的感情。
You're not running around saying a racial epithet in public, because you know somebody's going to take huge issue with it and say, why did you just say that word?
你不会在公共场合到处说种族绰号，因为你知道有人会对此提出很大的异议，并说，你为什么刚才说这个词？
And so with that community says it hurts them, which they do say that, then the argument that it's just this word that's been abstracted and now it's just a funny word and nobody cares, people care.
因此，那个社区说这伤害了他们，他们确实这么说，然后争论说这只是这个词被抽象了，现在它只是一个有趣的词，没有人关心，人们关心。
Guess what?
你猜怎么着？
People care.
人们关心。
People do care.
人们确实关心。
It does matter.
这确实很重要。
So that argument holds no water, I think.
所以我认为这个论点站不住脚。
Yeah.
是的。
Can I ask you, because you did, we're so kind and validating just then, and I want to return it a little bit.
我可以问你吗，因为你这样做了，我们当时非常友善和认可，我想回报一点。
As a parent, you said, I wish I'd known more when you were doing the show and you just had Elliot and you were trying to figure out how you could bring those two things together.
作为一名家长，你说，我希望当你做节目时我能知道更多，而你刚刚有了艾略特，你试图弄清楚如何将这两件事结合在一起。
That is a wildly intense experience to go through for anyone, even if there's nothing going on with your kid.
对于任何人来说，这都是一次极其激烈的经历，即使你的孩子没有发生任何事情。
Even if your job is a simple job, it's a lot to have a baby and then growing child and a job.
即使你的工作很简单，生孩子、成长中的孩子和工作也意味着很多。
I just want to validate that.
我只是想验证这一点。
I don't think you need to be like, God, I wish I had been better because although we always and always do, as parents as people, but I do want to ask, as a parent now, you have all this perspective, and Elliot's 18, and what are you excited about for him?
我不认为你需要这样说，天啊，我希望我能做得更好，因为虽然我们作为父母和人总是这样做，但我确实想问，作为现在的父母，你有所有这些观点，埃利奥特已经18岁了，你对他感到兴奋吗？
And on the flip side of that, what's keeping you up at night as the parent of a child who's going out into this world?
另一方面，作为即将进入这个世界的孩子的父母，是什么让您彻夜难眠？
Yeah, great question.
是的，很好的问题。
Thank you for that comment.
谢谢你的评论。
I do still, but that's a port of of comment.
我仍然这样做，但这只是评论的一部分。
I mean, I do still look, I want to say one thing on that, because I do still look back on it.
我的意思是，我仍然在看，我想说一件事，因为我仍然在回顾它。
I'll try not to beat myself up too much.
我会尽量不让自己太过自责。
But I regret that I had a certain kind of platform that I probably could have used to talk about it more.
但我很遗憾我有一个特定的平台，我可能可以用它来更多地谈论它。
Do you want to know the truth, right?
你想知道真相吗？
I think I was masking a little bit, right?
我想我有点掩饰了，对吧？
I was like, well, we'll see what happens.
我当时想，好吧，我们看看会发生什么。
You know, I wasn't like fully embracing his, he has a rare syndrome.
你知道，我不想完全拥抱他，他有一种罕见的综合症。
I don't know exactly which way it's going to go.
我不知道具体会走向哪条路。
There was some level of like denial or not fully embracing what was happening or not being able to compute it well enough to know how to write about it or talk about it.
在某种程度上，有人否认，或者没有完全接受正在发生的事情，或者无法很好地计算它，以至于不知道如何写或谈论它。
I was sort of slowly sharing it in my personal life with people, but it is an unknown road, a rare genetic syndrome.
我在个人生活中慢慢地与人们分享它，但这是一条未知的道路，一种罕见的遗传综合症。
There aren't that many people at Jacob's syndrome in the world.
世界上患有雅各布氏综合症的人并不多。
And even within that population, there's a lot of different manifestations of it.
即使在这个人群中，也有很多不同的表现形式。
50% of people at Jacob's syndrome have some sort of heart problem.
50% 的雅各布氏综合症患者患有某种心脏问题。
The other 50% don't.
其他 50% 则不然。
But that is a testament to the complicated cocktail of the human genome, why I'm missing basically the same parts of the 11th chromosome, they're just more or less, do some people's hearts not sort of form correctly, but others do, it's sort of incredibly fascinating.
但这证明了人类基因组的复杂性，为什么我缺少第 11 号染色体的基本相同部分，它们只是或多或少，有些人的心脏形状不正确，但其他人却如此，这有点令人难以置信的迷人。
That's why there's this amazing doctor that studies Jacob Simpson of Dr. Paul Grossfeld that is like the beacon of light to that community and like he's the reason for so much of the published medical literature, his research.
这就是为什么有一位出色的医生研究保罗·格罗斯菲尔德博士的雅各布·辛普森，他就像是那个社区的灯塔，就像他是这么多出版的医学文献和他的研究的原因一样。
I do a lot of fundraising to support his research and he's amazing but at that time I didn't know I didn't know exactly what it was going to be right and I didn't talk about it that much and I think that was my way of being a little bit like I'm just sailing under the radar I don't want people to see me or see my son this certain way like as if there's some kind of hiding from it or some kind of need to hide from it there was something resisting it in my mind like resisting sharing it wider than my, than the small handful of people and how I met your mother and my friends.
我做了很多筹款来支持他的研究，他很棒，但当时我不知道我不知道到底什么是正确的，我也没有谈论太多，我认为这有点像我只是在雷达下航行，我不想让人们以某种方式看到我或看到我的儿子，就像有某种隐藏它或某种需要隐藏它一样，我的脑海里有一些东西在抵制它，就像拒绝向比我更广泛的人、比少数人以及我如何认识你的母亲和我的朋友们分享。
And I think that's, I don't know, it just, it reminded me of that feeling like when you said you got caught or something, like the moment where like the, the, you have to sort of embrace this hard thing, right?
我想，我不知道，它只是让我想起了那种感觉，就像你说你被抓住了或者什么的，就像你必须接受这个艰难的事情的那一刻，对吧？
That's hard to share with the world and you feel vulnerable doing it, but you sort of grow into that role, I guess.
这很难与世界分享，而且你会觉得这样做很脆弱，但我想你会成长为这个角色。
Hopefully, I guess I'm trying to, but yeah, Yeah, so that's me, when Ellie gets a baby, here I am, he's 18.
希望，我想我正在努力，但是，是的，是的，这就是我，当艾莉生下孩子时，我就在这里，他18岁了。
In between, I feel like I've learned so much, so much.
在这期间，我感觉自己学到了很多很多。
He's amazing.
他太棒了。
He has taught me everything important to know.
他教了我所有重要的知识。
He is the most musical person I've ever met.
他是我见过的最有音乐天赋的人。
He is this wonderfully musical soul.
他就是这个美妙的音乐灵魂。
So imagine that this is a guy who he has a lot of fine and gross motor scoldaways and and spatial problems with spatial relationships and save their safety issues around that.
所以想象一下，这是一个有很多精细和粗大运动问题的人，以及空间关系的空间问题，并围绕这些问题解决他们的安全问题。
This is a guy who, he can't button a button.
这是一个连按钮都扣不上的人。
He can't really do handwriting, but he can play Led Zeppelin on the drums.
他不会真正写字，但他可以用鼓演奏齐柏林飞船。
He can play Radiohead on the drums.
他可以用鼓演奏Radiohead。
He can play the Pixies on the drums.
他可以用鼓演奏小精灵。
Basically, I've indoctrinated him to think it's 1996.
基本上，我已经向他灌输了现在是 1996 年的想法。
I was gonna say that's a pretty good music choice.
我想说这是一个非常好的音乐选择。
It's across the board.
这是全面的。
Jam is his biggest one.
果酱是他最大的一个。
I should say Pearl Jam.
我应该说珍珠酱。
He's basically like a dad rocker at the age 18.
18 岁时他基本上就像一位摇滚老爹。
He's like, Can you do the Addy Better voice to like bag it up then?
他说，你能用阿迪更好的声音来把它收拾起来吗？
Not in public, I can't.
不在公共场合，我不能。
If you walk by my house at the wrong moment, you might hear it and go, what is happening inside there?
如果你在错误的时间经过我家，你可能会听到声音然后走过去，看看里面发生了什么？
What's your address?
你的地址是什么？
But he, so I taught him, I'm a drummer.
但是他，所以我教他，我是鼓手。
I taught him drums.
我教他打鼓。
He got so good at the drums, I got kicked off the drums.
他的鼓打得非常好，我被踢出了鼓。
And now I just play guitar and sing and pretend to be Addy Better at times.
现在我只是弹吉他、唱歌，有时还假装是 Addy Better。
And we probably play like 50, 70 songs together.
我们可能会一起演奏 50、70 首歌曲。
We have like this catalog.
我们有这样的目录。
And so he, this is a guy drumming his heart.
所以他，这是一个鼓动他的心的人。
You have four different limbs doing four different things.
你有四个不同的肢体，做四件不同的事情。
Yeah, I can't do it at all.
是的，我根本做不到。
He can do that, but he can't button a button.
他可以做到这一点，但他无法按下按钮。
Zippering Zipper was in the last couple of years he got that.
Zippering Zipper是他近几年才得到的。
I mean, this is all to say one wonderful word, I think, to describe one, and not wonderful, an accurate word to describe him when people say, well, what word would a, the atypical learner idea is fairly applicable to him.
我的意思是，我认为，这一切都是为了用一个美妙的词来描述一个人，而不是一个美妙的、准确的词来描述他，当人们说，好吧，用什么词来形容，非典型学习者的想法相当适用于他。
He just has these different challenges and these different huge strengths.
他只是拥有这些不同的挑战和这些不同的巨大优势。
And it is so interesting to watch that journey.
观看这段旅程非常有趣。
He's funny, he's sweet, he's musical, and he just played drums in the pit band for his school musical.
他很有趣，他很可爱，他很有音乐天赋，他刚刚在学校音乐剧的乐队中打鼓。
And I'm basically in a band with my son.
我基本上和我儿子在一个乐队里。
And we do this, we do a high-metromother based fundraiser concert for that amazing doctor I just talked about, who's research.
我们这样做，我们为我刚才谈到的那位从事研究的出色医生举办了一场以高母亲为基础的筹款音乐会。
So we've done it three times now.
所以我们现在已经做了三次了。
If anyone's in New York, please follow me on social media.
如果有人在纽约，请在社交媒体上关注我。
That's so cool.
太酷了。
And check this out, because we do it once a year, and we have actors from the cast of How Metromother come, we have musicians who's music we use how much mother at this past one we had Josh Radner and Wolf Forte and the lead singer of Nada Serf and all an amazing lineup of people of all those stars and celebrities Elliot was the star of the night because I got him out and he played drums on four songs with us in front of 650 people we packed the Bowery Ballroom but that if you're asking where are what are those moments of joy what are those moments I wish I could go back in time how much mother was a very time jumpy show where we jump to flashback, flash forward.
看看这个，因为我们每年举办一次，我们有来自《Metromother come》演员阵容的演员，我们有音乐人，我们在过去的一届音乐剧中使用了多少母亲的音乐，我们有乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）和沃尔夫·福特（Wolf Forte）以及纳达·瑟夫（Nada Serf）的主唱，以及所有这些明星和名人的令人惊叹的阵容，埃利奥特（Elliot）是当晚的明星，因为我让他出来了，他在包厘街宴会厅的 650 人面前和我们一起演奏了四首歌，但是如果你问那些快乐的时刻在哪里，我希望我能回到过去，妈妈是一个非常时间跳跃的节目，我们跳到闪回，闪进。
If I could flash back to when my son was just born and I thought, how am I going to do this?
如果我能回到我儿子刚出生的时候，我会想，我该怎么办？
How are we going to do this?
我们要怎么做呢？
How is my wife going to do this?
我的妻子要怎么做呢？
How are we all going to do this?
我们大家要怎样做呢？
If I could have had a crystal ball and gone back now, I'm 50, basically, and I go back with a crystal ball and I just get to give like 30 year old Craig or whatever, 32 year old Craig, just one glimpse in a crystal ball, it might be Elliott playing drums in front of 650 people at Valerie Ballroom with with a full band, including professional musicians, and honestly killing it.
如果我能有一个水晶球，现在回去，我基本上已经 50 岁了，我带着水晶球回去，我就像 30 岁的克雷格或其他什么，32 岁的克雷格，只是水晶球中的一瞥，可能是埃利奥特在瓦莱丽舞厅的 650 人面前打鼓，和一支包括专业音乐家在内的完整乐队一起，诚实地杀死它。
Honestly, nailing it.
老实说，钉它。
He is so rock steady.
他是如此坚如磐石。
He was so great.
他太棒了。
I was up on guitar singing those songs.
我弹着吉他唱那些歌。
We did a few comedy songs from how much mother that Carter and I wrote.
我们根据卡特和我写的《妈妈》创作了几首喜剧歌曲。
And I messed up the lyrics at one point, and he was rock steady.
我有一次把歌词弄乱了，而他却表现得很稳定。
I totally blanked on some lyrics.
我对一些歌词完全茫然。
I had to like, bam, for a second, and he was rock steady, and just so, I was so proud of him.
我不得不喜欢，砰，有一秒钟，他非常稳定，正因为如此，我为他感到骄傲。
And just one of those things you're like, I just wish I could have seen that moment.
只是你喜欢的那些事情之一，我只是希望我能看到那一刻。
And that could be any number of moments for any number of people, but those gifts you can't imagine when you're catastrophizing and your worst-case scenario and you're reading the Google page about the genetic syndrome and reading every worst thing and going, all of those are going to be in my sense.
对于任何数量的人来说，这可能是任何数量的时刻，但是当你陷入灾难和最坏的情况时，你无法想象那些礼物，当你正在阅读有关遗传综合症的谷歌页面并阅读每一件最糟糕的事情时，所有这些都将在我的感觉中。
And then what you realize, again, coming back to humanizing people, then you look at the human being that is your child and you realize this is a human being.
然后你再次意识到，回到人性化，然后你看着你的孩子，你意识到这是一个人。
There's a lot of factors here.
这里面有很多因素。
Yes, he's missing a little piece of one of his 11th chromosomes, but he's him.
是的，他的第 11 条染色体缺失了一小部分，但他就是他。
He's not reducible to WebMD page of symptoms.
他无法将症状简化为 WebMD 页面。
He's not reducible to the R word.
他不能简化为“R”这个词。
He's not reducible to anything because he is a beautiful human being, and he's sorry.
他不能被简化为任何东西，因为他是一个美丽的人，他很抱歉。
He's going to be more than anybody could ever imagine.
他将超越任何人的想象。
He's going to be himself and he cannot be reduced to any one thing.
他将做他自己，他不能被简化为任何一件事。
But I think that that's the gift of it, the challenge of it is wanting the world to see him that way.
但我认为这就是它的礼物，它的挑战是希望世界以这种方式看待他。
And now that he's 18, I want him to go out in the world and be seen with that sort of robust, generous, open-minded approach rather than something reductive, and that how his next few years will go and what his education will be and how that will all work is that stuff keeps me up at night.
现在他已经 18 岁了，我希望他能够走出去，以那种稳健、慷慨、开放的态度而不是简单化的方式被人看到，他接下来的几年将如何发展，他的教育将会是什么样，以及这一切将如何运作，这些都是让我夜不能寐的事情。
And it's a lot of problems to solve.
还有很多问题需要解决。
And like I said at the beginning of the conversation, it's, it's range, how much it is in the wilderness.
就像我在谈话开始时所说的那样，它的范围，它在荒野中的距离。
And it's each person you talk to who's gone through it as the parents who've gone through it, trying to devise sort of next steps for their child with collaboratively with their child.
与你交谈的每个人都经历过这个过程，就像父母也经历过这个过程一样，他们试图与孩子合作，为孩子制定下一步的计划。
Everyone is doing an improv game.
每个人都在做即兴游戏。
There's just everyone's like, well, we did this for a couple years and we figured this out.
每个人都会说，好吧，我们做了几年，然后我们就解决了这个问题。
And we found this thing where it's this company that has people who, who have disabilities and they welcome them.
我们发现这家公司有残疾人并且他们欢迎他们。
And And then he did have a couple of, it's all like this, this in constant game of improvisation.
然后他确实有几个，都是这样，在不断的即兴创作中。
Yeah.
是的。
Sorry.
对不起。
Got emotional there.
那里情绪激动。
It's funny.
很有趣。
You can tell there's just so much in this conversation.
你可以看出这次谈话内容非常丰富。
There's a lot, right?
有很多，对吧？
There's a lot.
有很多。
We're looking at it a lot and all of this is in my book and this is like, I'm trying to channel all of those fears and keep you up at night and find out how can I make this funny?
我们看了很多，所有这些都在我的书中，这就像，我试图引导所有这些恐惧，让你彻夜难眠，看看我怎样才能让这变得有趣？
How can I make this human?
我怎样才能使这个人成为人类？
How can I write about this in a way that that people will relate to?
我怎样才能以一种人们会产生共鸣的方式来写这个？
whether or not they're in this experience.
无论他们是否有这种经历。
Because I think the experience of being a parent and being in a family, my book is about being a parent and being in a family, it's not, it's not.
因为我认为作为父母和在家庭中的经历，我的书是关于作为父母和在家庭中的，不是，不是。
It is a family with one of the members has a disability, but I think every parent, there's this great quote that I love that like, I'll get wrong now.
这是一个家庭，其中一名成员患有残疾，但我认为每一位家长，我都喜欢这句话，我现在会错了。
But parenthood is letting your heart come out of your body and walk around that zone.
但为人父母就是让你的心离开你的身体，在那个区域里行走。
Yeah, it's when your heart lives outside.
是的，当你的心住在外面的时候。
When your heart lives outside, yeah, yeah.
当你的心住在外面时，是的，是的。
And it's like, that's parenthood, that's all parenthood.
这就像，这就是父母身份，这就是父母身份。
That's not disability-based parenthood.
这不是基于残疾的父母身份。
That is all parenthood.
这就是所有的父母身份。
Yes, so accurate.
是的，非常准确。
And what is the future for your child?
您孩子的未来是什么？
How can you make the best future for your child?
如何为孩子创造最好的未来？
That is just universal.
这只是普遍现象。
All of our parents wanted that for us.
我们所有的父母都希望我们这样。
And we, if and when we become parents, we want that for our children.
当我们成为父母时，我们希望我们的孩子也能这样。
That is universal.
这是普遍的。
And that's what my book's about.
这就是我的书的内容。
And that's what keeps me up at night.
这就是让我彻夜难眠的原因。
But it's also, you know, my son has shown me time and again that I don't have to be so afraid and that he can do so much.
但你知道，我的儿子一次又一次地向我表明，我不必那么害怕，他可以做很多事情。
And yeah, there's a lot of gifts in this journey.
是的，这次旅程有很多礼物。
There's a lot of gifts in this journey.
这次旅程有很多礼物。
I love that he sounds like just an amazing guy.
我喜欢他听起来是个了不起的人。
He's a really good guy.
他真是个好人。
And I love that you just wanted him to see, I don't know, this is how we all feel, right?
我喜欢你只是想让他看到，我不知道，这就是我们所有人的感受，对吗？
We want our kids to be seen as whole people just for the wonder that they are.
我们希望我们的孩子被视为完整的人，只是因为他们本身就是一个奇迹。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
And I'll say this one other thing about of passing or masking.
我要说的是关于传递或掩蔽的另一件事。
In the last couple of, in the last year or so, my son has lost all his hair.
在过去的几年里，在过去一年左右的时间里，我儿子的头发全部掉光了。
It's a very rare symptom of Jacob's syndrome, almost to the point where we know a couple other people with Jacob's syndrome this happened to.
这是雅各氏综合症的一种非常罕见的症状，几乎我们知道其他几个患有雅各氏综合症的人也发生过这种情况。
And so he's completely bald, his eyebrows are mostly gone.
所以他完全秃了，眉毛大部分都消失了。
He looks different than he used to, right?
他看起来和以前不一样了，对吧？
And he instantly looks more different than he ever did, if that makes sense.
如果这有道理的话，他立刻看起来就比以前更加不同了。
He's more recognizable instantly as someone that has something medical going on or something disability-based going on.
他更容易被认出是一个正在经历医疗或残疾的人。
I think people see him differently than they did a year ago, right?
我认为人们对他的看法与一年前不同，对吗？
And it's so interesting that idea of masking or being caught or whatever it is because I miss him having his hair because his hair was beautiful and every now and again he goes, I wish I still had my hair.
掩盖或被抓住或其他什么的想法非常有趣，因为我想念他有他的头发，因为他的头发很漂亮，他时不时地走，我希望我仍然有我的头发。
Other times he goes, I'm just like the drummer of Radiohead, It feels so like he's bald and he's awesome.
其他时候他去的时候，我就像Radiohead的鼓手，感觉他很秃头，但他很棒。
And I'm like, yes, he is bald and he's awesome.
我想，是的，他是秃头，而且他很棒。
And it's just really interesting.
这真的很有趣。
It's interesting now to go through the world with him and people look at him differently than they used to.
现在和他一起环游世界很有趣，人们对他的看法也与以前不同了。
But also there's, I think it's good because it's like, let me embrace that new piece, right?
但还有，我认为这很好，因为它就像，让我拥抱那件新作品，对吗？
Each new piece, each new chapter, each new part of this, you've got to wrap your arms around it and go like this is what it is.
每一个新的作品，每一个新的章节，每一个新的部分，你都必须拥抱它，就像它本来的样子一样。
And we will figure out life like this now.
我们现在就会明白这样的生活。
And it's not really gonna change that much.
而且它真的不会改变那么多。
And maybe it'll make everything more honest.
也许这会让一切变得更加诚实。
Maybe I think everything.
也许我什么都想。
Maybe we'll discover gifts in that that we didn't know about.
也许我们会发现我们不知道的礼物。
So it's just interesting, that idea.
所以这个想法很有趣。
The idea that there should ever be any masking or shaming or hiding or passing is so unfortunate that anybody ever has to feel that way.
应该有任何掩饰、羞辱、隐藏或传递的想法是如此不幸，以至于任何人都必须有这种感觉。
I think that circles all the way back to the way we talk about and think about disability in America and the world.
我认为这可以追溯到我们谈论和思考美国和世界残疾问题的方式。
What words do we use, the space we make to be either inclusive or exclusive, disinclusive, the disincluding people, diminishing people using derogatory terms, there's no one would feel the need to hide or pass or feel shame if we were in a society that didn't use things like the R word and that instead said, how do we...
我们使用什么词语，我们创造的空间是包容性的还是排他性的，非包容性的，排斥人的，使用贬义词贬低人的，如果我们生活在一个不使用 R 词这样的东西的社会，没有人会觉得有必要隐藏或通过或感到羞耻，而是说，我们如何......
How do we include, how do we open up the world?
我们如何包容、如何开放世界？
How do we make a space in our society for everybody?
我们如何在社会中为每个人创造一个空间？
Craig's upcoming novel is called That's Not How It Happened.
克雷格即将出版的小说名为《事情不是这样发生的》。
It comes out this fall and is available for pre-order now.
该产品将于今年秋季上市，现已开放预订。
You can find a link to that and Craig's podcast, How We Made Your Mother, in the show notes.
您可以在节目笔记中找到该内容和克雷格播客“我们如何创造了您的母亲”的链接。
Hyper Focus is made by me, Ray Jacobson, and Cody Nelson.
Hyper Focus 是由我、雷·雅各布森 (Ray Jacobson) 和科迪·尼尔森 (Cody Nelson) 制作的。
Our music comes from Blue Dot Sessions.
我们的音乐来自 Blue Dot Sessions。
Our research correspondent is Dr. K.
我们的研究通讯员是 K 博士。
J.
J。
Wint.
温特。
Calvin Kenne is our video producer and video is edited by Alyssa Shea.
Calvin Kenne 是我们的视频制作人，视频由 Alyssa Shea 编辑。
Brianna Berry is our production director and Neil Drumming is our editorial director.
Brianna Berry 是我们的制作总监，Neil Drumming 是我们的编辑总监。
Production support is provided by Andrew Rector.
制作支持由 Andrew Rector 提供。
If you have any questions for us or ideas for future episodes, write me an email or send a voice memo to hyperfocus at understood.org.
如果您对我们有任何疑问或对未来剧集有任何想法，请给我写一封电子邮件或将语音备忘录发送到 Understanding.org 上的 hyperfocus。
This show is brought to you by understood.org.
该节目由 Understanding.org 为您带来。
Our executive directors are Laura Key, Scott Kosher and Jordan Davidson.
我们的执行董事是 Laura Key、Scott Kosher 和 Jordan Davidson。
is a non-profit dedicated to empowering people with learning and thinking differences like ADHD and dyslexia.
是一个非营利组织，致力于帮助患有多动症和阅读障碍等学习和思维差异的人们。
If you want to help us continue this work, you can donate at understood.org Give
如果您想帮助我们继续这项工作，您可以在 Understanding.org 上捐款